if you were to look at the current uh
system that we have we typically ask
this one question i'm curious to know
what your answer is going to be guy
asked me this question yes i'm like you
know no one's ever asked me the question
that i've asked others i asked joe rogan
this question out of the five
uh uh
organizations and individuals i'll give
you tell me who's got the most power
president of the united states virtual
governments which is you know facebook
youtube twitter all those guys we call
them virtual government and then you got
the educational system you got
mainstream media or you got the
billionaires in order of top five who
would you put as the most powerful not
least powerful one one more time
president
virtual government
educational system mainstream media
billionaires
so it's
i think it's relatively easy
billionaires have the most power by an
order of magnitude a way way way more
the president has the least power by an
order of magnitude because politicians
are basically servants
they their waiters and waitresses that
the mainstream media does marketing for
uh they take an order hey uh donor would
like this and they execute the order
okay i would pass a bill in favor of the
donors so why did for example why did
ted cruz turn around on a dime oh i'm
gonna get trump i can't believe he said
that about my wife and i'm gonna get him
and he said that about my dad and he's
on dishonorable man and then he's like
i'm gonna phone bank for donald trump i
love donald trump please re-elect donald
trump okay hey he's true story by the
way 100 true a he's a [ __ ] okay
uh but b let me explain to you why he's
a [ __ ] because when he gave the speech
at the convention and did not endorse
trump he then went up to his daddy which
is robert mercer that's his donor that
gave him 13 million dollars look again
we're businessman patrick somebody gives
you 13 million dollars they expect
something in return okay especially in
politics in business they expect a
return in politics what do they expect
they still expect their return
but through corruption okay so when when
he goes up to the turn on investment
exactly when he goes up to the suite of
the mercers robert and rebecca they
slammed a door in his face they got a
new boy it's donald trump and
ted cruz miscalculated
because he lost his donor that's why he
was like oh i'm sorry
you saw my wife all you like i know i
never really she's not that pretty
anyway it's fine right she's ugly donald
trump what do you need me to do okay
because he is that's who they are they
so the president barely has any power
when when the donors tell uh biden
you're not gonna pass the 15 minimum
wage shut up
and do as you're told biden says yes sir
absolutely sir i can prove it i forced
the vote the young turks did a petition
that forced bernie to introduce 15
minimum wage in the corona virus relief
bill they had it in there originally
they took it out and they were never
going to vote on it why because it was
going to be embarrassing to the
democrats then bernie does do the vote
he did the right thing wonderful okay
guess what it was just republicans eight
democrats voted against it including the
two delaware senators
the two delaware senators are not voting
without checking with biden there is top
allies that is biden saying i didn't
mean it i was lying the whole time i'm
against 15 minimum wage the whole time
pretending that he's in favor of it if
you watch mainstream media they tell you
joe biden's in favor of a 15 minimum
wage no it was a lie so mainstream media
second most powerful on that list
but they're also servants the
the wealthy are at the top corporations
are at the top everyone else serves them
okay the educational system
that's had that is a variety so because
it has a history right and sometimes
exactly sometimes it's wonderful like in
the 1950s and 60s education in new york
was the best in the world and it
produced uh
amazing businessmen entertainers you
name it right so they uh when i was
growing up we had great public schools i
went to a public school in new jersey
right now it's an absolute disaster in
places like california why because they
lowered the tax base and they privatize
the schools and they funnel the money to
private schools and they starve the
public schools so the educational system
is important because that's where we
teach culture now the right wing would
agree with me that we teach culture
there but we disagree on what we should
teach so you put education three
uh i i think education three uh
presidents five so who what's left what
was the digital media virtual goal oh no
my bad virtual government is is uh now
now you're thinking about no no no no no
they're number three
yeah but they're almost at number two so
you got billionaires at the top yeah
then you got legacy media number two
then and then virtual government's
digital media number three that's right
educational system number four and at
the bottom of the totem pole the
president united states definitely so
here's how i have it okay
uh
i have president at the bottom just like
you do i don't think president is you
got eight years what are you going to be
doing and quite frankly
eight years you got to have congress on
your side senator there's a lot of
moving parts for you to be able to do a
lot of things done and they're funding
you from the back so you're working for
you guys agree uh that part i agree
absolutely at the at the second to the
lowest i put mainstream media because
mainstream media is a byproduct of the
money guys meaning
mainstream media is nobody without the
funders which is billionaires
billionaires make mainstream media
so i put mainstream media at fourth i
put uh billionaires at third i put
educational system at second because
it's got a long life span kind of like
what you were talking about so if one
side of the political party gets the
educational system you got them for
decades so if you got for every one
conservative professor 12 are you know
on the liberal side
you got a monopoly there that's a
full-on monopoly so that's problematic
because you're able to indoctrinate
younger generation coming up that's a
lot of power that's number two and i put
number one at virtual government because
i think those guys are becoming just as
powerful as the government if not bigger
uh you know they can do a lot of
different things they can have a lot of
control over other things and you have
to go through them they're not going
away so you can do a lot of things you
want to do but you kind of have to go
through them the virtual governments but
you put billionaires at the top if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]